hey everyone welcome to apogee up close
my name is irfan bakke i'm a customer
engineer with google cloud
helping our customers make better
architectural decisions as well as
better api management decisions
and today we'll be talking about
insights driven api
programs and the objective
is just to share our philosophy on
analytics and monitoring
and related to your business right i'll
i'll give you a lot of examples of how
our customers are leveraging
uh insights to make their businesses
better to make the api programs better
and then toward the end i'll take you
through a demo
that will showcase everything that we
talk about in the presentation
but the central idea really is that a
business needs real-time insights on
multiple different levels
to be agile and i'll show you today on
how you can get
those insights so let's dive right into
it
right i'm sure you're familiar with
apogee
it sits in the middle of all of your
services
in your applications and all of the data
that goes through
between your applications and your
services it goes to apigee
and the good thing about this is that
apogee has a lot of data passing through
and it can tell you can give you the
right insights on how your services are
doing
both on a business level as well as
on an operational level and
when we are talking about this data
right
one thing to keep in mind is that the
data is usually associated with a
particular entity
so on the left you have the customer on
the right you have your backend systems
and that's how the data flows left to
right and right to left
and it is associated with a customer
and application and a developer and it
accesses
particular apis um which
are part of different products of yours
and
in turn it those apis in apogee then
they
interact with specific backend systems
right
so all of these insights are very
specific to the particular entity
thus they can give you a good glean
on how your business and your api
program is doing so now let me tell you
about
our philosophy behind insights we look
at insights in
a lot of different levels and the first
level is just record business right
everything starts at your core business
kpis
what is your business strategy and what
are the metrics that you need to track
to achieve it
and you would want to track that and you
can do it in apigee in
a very close to real time basis be it
your revenue
or your subscriptions or the health of
your marketing campaigns
you can track all of those insights in
apigee
the second one is the insights about
your api program
right how is your api program doing how
many developers are signing up in a
particular week
the different applications the
developers are making how are they
consuming your apis what are
the experiences that the end users are
getting so all of those insights you can
get
from a good api management platform like
apigee the next one is at a product
level
right so within your api program you
would be exposing a lot of different
apis bundled together
as a product that represent a cohesive
functionality
and you want to see how those products
are being consumed by your customers
and you want to see how one product
relates to the other
and figure out how you can make them
better invest the right resources
to make them better and lastly the
operational level analytics
for your operations teams and these have
to be real time so if there's something
wrong
in your apis on apogee or even in your
backend systems you want to get alerted
in real time with the right amount of
information that will
help you solve that particular error and
you'd be able to get that
with apogee so now let me talk about
some of our customers
that are using apigee analytics on all
of these different levels
so one of the customers i want to talk
about is t-mobile t-mobile
is um one of the largest
telecommunications providers in the
united states
and they are reinventing themselves as a
technology company
they are modernizing the entire stack
and they're using apogee
as the api layer on top of everything to
manage
the apis and govern them and all of that
so
one of their key business metrics that
they track are subscriptions
right and they're able to get business
insights into
how the api program is supporting that
key business strategy and how many
subscriptions they're driving
so thinking about t-mobile it has a good
online presence
it also has a very good brick and mortar
concrete offline presence right uh it
has
thousands of stores across the us but at
the same time they're also selling
through big
big box retailers and they would want to
find
out what kinds of demographics
resonate better in one channel versus
the other
right the people who would buy t-mobile
subscriptions
in the retailer target may be of a
different demographic
than folks that buy the subscriptions at
best buy or walmart
right and you want to make sure that you
are appealing to them you're providing
the right kind of product to each one of
them
and that's possible by gaining the right
insights from that demographic
the other customer i want to talk about
is domino's pizza
now you would think that domino's is in
the pizza delivery business
but actually they are in a b2b business
servicing their franchise owners
and these franchisees they have um
they have their own it systems usually
and then domino's needs a way to
integrate
into their delivery systems and their
payment systems and all of that and
they're able to do that
with apogee but at the same time to stay
competitive
and lure the the franchise owners in
staying with dominoes and opening up
even more franchises
they need to provide them with relevant
insights
on how they can make their programs
better
and with a platform like apogee as all
of the data is flowing through
they would be able to give them insights
on
how what what does the best delivery
experience look like
right who are the target demographics
what are they interested in
across different geographies and what
are the success factors and success
criterias
that the franchise owners can implement
to make their businesses better
the other customer i want to talk to you
about is walgreens
and walgreens is really a classic
example of
a customer that has developed a robust
developer ecosystem
walgreens if you're aware it is one of
the largest pharmacy chains
in the united states and back
in 2008 they started to experience
a drop in their photo business because
folks weren't using film roles anymore
and they were
using their smartphones instead to take
pictures
and then it was really important for
them to understand the end user
behaviors
and figure out how to get those users
back
well they found out that they were
taking pictures with their smartphones
but they
still wanted to get those pictures
printed
so they created some native applications
mobile as well as desktop
to get to to basically enable them to
get
those photos printed at the nearby
walgreens and that restored
some of their business but they said hey
i think
there is some more potential here and it
started
to get insights into what kinds of
pictures
were these customers printing and they
found out that a lot of this traffic
was coming from other photo services
that would enhance
uh the customers photos for example at
halloween time
you would upload a picture to one of
these services
and decorate it with pumpkins or
something right
so they were experiencing a lot of
traffic from such services
they said all right how about i expose
my api
my photo prints api to these different
applications and services
and incentivize them to
[Music]
route the traffic to get the photos
printed at a nearby walgreens store
so they did that and their ecosystem
exploded right there were actually net
new apps that the developers were making
just to tap into the incentives that
walgreens would give them
to to direct traffic to their stores
so that was very successful and then
they replicated that model
uh to other products as well so now
they have a plethora of products ranging
from
prescription refills and rewards
programs and home delivery services
that are basically just apis that
they're exposing
and they're being integrated into
developers applications
and thereby giving more business and
traffic
to walgreens and they were able to do so
by really understanding
their end customers and their shopping
patterns
as well as understanding developers what
they need and incentivizing them
to to to partner with them and send them
the right traffic
the next thing i want to talk about is
operational insights and monitoring
and this is actually used by a lot of
our customers and a lot of different
verticals so i won't give you a
particular customer's example
but let me let me tell you about the
motivation actually of
why we um why we created
the monitoring module in apogee
so um some of the largest retailers
in the u.s and across the globe actually
are applied customers
and at critical times of the year
like the new year sale or the black
friday or cyber monday sale
they experience enormous amount of
traffic
right so for example in 2018 black
friday
we experienced close to 110
000 transactions per second sustained
over long durations of time
and it's important that these services
for these customers they're up and
running without any disruption
because every second of disruption could
cost them
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
dollars in revenue
right so apogee
has a really robust api availability
rate
um we surpass our slas but our customers
said that hey sometimes there are
things on our end that we need to
troubleshoot some some of our services
get down
for a variety of different reasons and
we would love
to get some alerts for us to be able to
fix
those issues fast and get get up and
running really fast so that was the
motivation behind
apogee monitoring it addresses
a particular need for the operations
teams right
there's a lot of pressure these days for
them to resolve issues very fast quickly
diagnose issues
and the data that apogee has which
is specific to the entities accessing
the apis
as well as services that the api is tied
to
in a different policies in your in your
proxies
and where exactly that error might be
occurring
is very useful in diagnosing these api
issues
so this is a diagram of how apogee
monitoring differs from just generic
synthetic monitoring
the thing i want you to focus on
is that the alerts that you get
they are precise they tell you exactly
where the error has
occurred they're contextual um if
the error is due to a race condition
right
if it's intermittent it'll help you zero
in on what exactly is wrong
and what is triggering that particular
error so just to sum it up apogee
analytics
actually covers all of the personas
that need insights into the api program
to make it better right it is your
business owner
to get insights on the strategy for api
program
and how it's doing with relation to the
different kpis that the business team
has set
so the api team to monitor the health of
the api program
and figure out what is gaining traction
what needs more resources
to the app developer to gain insights
into particular api proxies
in applications and
to ops teams to get real-time monitoring
alerts
and help in diagnosing the issues
so at this um let me jump right into a
demo
so this is how the apigee platform looks
right you have a place to design
your apis you have a place to create
build your apis
productize them publish them and all of
that and then you have a place for
analytics and to the left of the screen
as you can see these
are the out of the box dashboards that
you have
to target specific personas within your
organization
um i would like to begin with
developers because once you have an api
program usually the first thing you
think about
is how are my developers
consuming my apis what is my engagement
rate and all of that so this dashboard
will give us just that
so right now as you can see
there is a funnel on the screen and
you'll be able to see how many
developers have signed up
for the api program in our of the
developers that have signed up
how many have actually created
applications
how many of those applications are
active and how many of those
applications
are highly active right and down below
you'll be able
to see how is each of the application
performing what is the traffic that they
are
running to the platform what is the
error rate and all of that and then you
can dig in further
to analyze the high level metrics the
next thing
that you would be interested in just at
a high level
is the traffic composition right just
tell me what
are the top 10 proxies that
are receiving the most traffic tell me
what are the top
applications that are consuming
my services what are top 10 products
that are
being accessed being consumed and who
are the developers
that are the most active on my platform
right so that is
more a high level overview of the health
of your api program if you're looking at
the end users
if you're a product manager you would
want to gauge where are my end users
located
right um you'll be able to do that with
the geo map attribute with uh with
apigee over here as you can see
i have a lot of users coming from united
states but i also have presence
global presence in australia and norway
and china pakistan
a lot of places so if i click on the us
i'll be able to see the different states
where traffic's coming from most of it
looks like it's coming from california
i can dig in deeper and see what are
different counties
that are sending me this traffic
you can also see what are the devices
that are
accessing your your applications so over
here you can see that
the most popular platform looks like
it's chrome in the internet explorer
and so on and so forth most of the
traffic is coming from the pc
and a lot of my users are also using the
smartphone
mostly from from windows also from ios
and all of that
all right so the next thing i want to
show you is
the api metrics on a product level
as well as on an api proxy level right
so if i click on api proxy performance
on this dashboard you'll be able to see
what is the health
of all of my api proxies for the traffic
that
you've gotten what are the successes and
what are the errors
right you can see that oh my error rate
is is pretty high
actually it's eight percent so just i
need to
make a mental note that i need to dig in
to why
what is causing that error rate so we'll
do that in just a second
you can also see that my average
response time for the proxy
is just a bit over 100 milliseconds for
the target
it's a bit over 250 milliseconds these
are
the traffic patterns by proxy
and there's the average response time
for each of the proxies
in the same times this is for your
proxies that you are
exposing on apogee right you can also
get
the same kind of information for your
target back-ends that
the proxies are in turn hitting to get
the right data to execute the
right logic and you can see that the
traffic by target
tells you what the traffic patterns are
it also tells you that most or all of it
is successful right your back end is not
throwing any errors which is good
uh your response time average proxy
is about 130 average target is
close to 300 and it also tells you a bit
about the payload
you can also do latency analysis and
cash performance and all of that let me
take a look at error code analysis let's
see what kinds of errors are we throwing
so all of the errors are proxy errors we
knew that
and a majority of those errors
are 400 errors right and four xx mostly
authentication um and in bad requests
and all of that which is good
we want to deny those requests but a
small
percentage of it is also 500 5x errors
we should look into that what exactly is
going on there it also tells me what is
the error by proxy it looks like my
product
search proxy is receiving or generating
the most amount of errors
so we'll we'll take a look at that airs
by target
um and also proxy errors by response
code and most of the response code
is 401 or 500 in some 502s
so we'll look into that as well
now let's let's dive right into
um some of the business level metrics so
i had mentioned that we have a lot of
customers that are
using these these tools to gain business
level insights
on their revenues and on their marketing
campaigns and all of that so let me
show you how you can do it so these are
what i showed you are out of the box
reports
you have a lot of metrics and data
available so that you can create your
own custom reports
so let's say you are a big box retailer
and you have a lot of retail locations
all across the globe
for that let's say i want a revenue
report on how each one of my locations
are doing so i'll run this report
for the past hour as i just wanted to be
real time
just to monitor the health and it will
tell me that hey most um
the majority or at the highest revenue
grossing store was my us 15
and my stores in india norway pakistan
are doing pretty well as well
as they are in the top ten right
let's say on the other hand you are
running
a marketing organization and you want to
see the health of your marketing
campaigns then let's take a look at the
marketing report
let's run it for the past hour
so over here you can see that your
traffic is divided into three different
blocks and one
chunk is from social media so let's take
a look in there as you can see the
report is interactive
it tells me that i have a few different
campaigns running
one is a data privacy campaign there's
also the money back guarantee campaign
all of that
and it tells me what is a traffic
composition from each one of these
it looks like my expert compensation
campaign
um is grossing the least amount of
traffic so i hope that
i'm also spending the least amount of
money on that and
the revenue per dollar spent on that
campaign
is worth my time right so let's click on
the data privacy campaign
look look at what kinds of um
channels that the traffic is coming from
it looks like uh most of it is coming
from blogs there's also
some from google linkedin some
influencer marketing going on
in the least amount of traffic from
twitter and instagram
so it gives me a good insight into
what is working for my campaigns versus
what is not working
so now lastly what i want to show you is
api monitoring and api monitoring
is about how is the health of
your api program in real time
so what you're seeing right now is
basically a dashboard it tells you what
is the tps
that your org is experiencing what is
the error rate towards the latency and
all of that
so one feature i want to call out over
here is the alerting feature
so over here i've set a 500 error alert
to alert me whenever my proxy surpass
certain threshold
for the 500 errors and that threshold
i've said is that if there is a
constant rate of 3 or higher
for five minutes then please alert me
and send me an alert to this particular
email
you can choose whatever mode you want
you can integrate with anything you want
with webhook or pagerduty or slack
or email so um
if i go to my inbox
i was actually getting some 500 alerts
and i got a few alerts um just
recently so let me take a look at this
that i got
about a day ago and it tells me that
there is a playbook for me to use to
troubleshoot
that alert it also gives me the details
on exactly what the alert is
so let me let me click on view details
so it'll take me
to a report um in the investigation
panel
on api monitoring it tells me that hey
the status quo is 500
and here was the spike that i'm looking
at
um it was constant or it was it was
pretty
stable um at that threshold for about
five minutes
and that's how it got triggered is right
here right it tells me
that the rate limit policy
that i have is triggering this so now i
have a pretty decent idea
of what exactly is going on right i
click on this it tells me that the
environment is production
this is the proxy so if you recall from
earlier
the product search proxy was also a
proxy that was um
that was throwing the most errors so i'm
not surprised by this
and looks like a lot of applications are
affected by
this particular error right so that's
good to know
and also gives me some other detail in
terms of the message processor
and also the target that
my api proxy is is calling
as part of these api calls
and down below it tells me
that most of the errors are generated
from the proxy
itself and there are
very few from the target so 3 500 from
the proxy itself
so now i know exactly where to go right
i know the
particular proxy that's that is impacted
and know the policy within the proxy
that is throwing these errors
so let me now go to develop let me click
on
api proxies and
now i'll go into the product search
proxy
and i'll go into develop and
this is the policy the spiker's policy
that is throwing those errors and looks
like i'm saying that hey
if i receive more than three requests
per second then please
throw errors like don't don't let let
them pass through because i think that
is higher than i expect
i think three requests per second um
let's say i do some analysis i look at
the capacity and backend systems and
feel like you know
i could probably increase it to seven
requests per second and save it
and now it's deployed and basically
that's it now i should expect those
error rates to go down because my spike
rs policy will get triggered less often
so this is basically what the apogee
analytics
and monitoring looks like
so that's it for today thank you for
joining you can find more webinars
uh coming out every week so please tune
in for that and you can also find
recordings of our past webinars on our
youtube channel
thanks again for joining take care bye